this is the Olympics of climate change
if you're not here you're not in the
game and the game is to do something
urgently we have the political will to
change and it really is the seminal
meeting of leaders to determine what we
do to combat this problem this morning
we're setting up for a brief interview
between Arnold Schwarzenegger our
correspondent and Todd Stern the climate
negotiator for the United States we
found this kind of hidden hallway here
to do the interview because every time
Arnold shows up at this conference
he's absolutely mom she's like the
climate change
celebrity everyone is convenien here for
this big climate summit and there's a
lot of excitement but all that really
matters what China does trying to try to
need to lead the way here
I think Arnold's really interested in
seeing and hearing how China can be a
leader on climate change and hopefully
bring some other players to the table
who can make major commitments so that
we can meet some of these goals of the
cop okay enjoy China is the big elephant
in the room and you know if they don't
make a move no one makes them moving off
the seems to what is the story on China
we've worked together with them much
more closely in the last few years than
were ever before I think China is
enormous ly important nobody more
important than China China has made
these bold commitments to reduce their
emissions and basically turn the
aircraft carrier around
what exactly are they doing how fast are
they doing it this year's all about
solutions another but just to say
scaring people and say this is the
progress diploma he says look here's the
saloon right here's what's being done
right now think what's really impressive
about Arnold Schwarzenegger is that he's
constantly thinking of ways to make
climate change accessible to the general
public and he feels that the show that
years of living dangerously has the
opportunity to inspire people to become
part of this movement that's needed
right now